Dad, I know you think I'm crazy.
but I feel her
I hear her heartbeat
she's so close
so what does her heartbeat sound like
mighty
and after your death
and I need you to be strong
strong heart
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
new Avatar the way of Water trailer video there's
a whole bunch of easter eggs here we know a little
bit more about what's actually going on with the
characters in the movie it's been 13 years post
all the memes if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos I will
do like a full breakdown in Easter eggs video for
the movie when it does come out in December and
when we get a little bit closer also do a movie
ticket giveaway for it too but the new trailer
gives you a little bit more with the characters
we actually hear more for Sigourney Weaver's new
character who is one of the daughters of Jake
and natiri they have a really crazy explainer for
how they brought Sigourney Weaver back like James
Cameron brought her back because of course she
brings Sigourney Weaver back she's an amazing
actress but her character Grace Augustine died
during the events of the first movie and they
uploaded her consciousness into that giant World
brain the navi worshiped that calling it The God
Eywa is like a giant superorganism world brain
they haven't completely explained yet there's
a sort of mystical and biological qualities to
it that they'll explore throughout the sequels
they kind of implied that their daughter here
played by Sigourney Weaver has this connection
to it and can feel its heartbeat it seems like
during this later fight scene too she's almost
trying to use the power of that world brain to
influence all the creatures around them but the
basic synopsis for the movie is just that Jake
Sully and atiri have formed a family in the past
13 14 years it's been about 13 years since the
first movie came out but I believe in the movie
they say it's been 14 years chronologically since
the events of the first film recently they've had
to leave the jungle regions of Pandora and they're
moving to this water tribe during the movie there
are currently seven members of their family they
have three biological children and two adopted
children the oldest child is a male named natayam
the second child is another male named Loach
their youngest biological Child is This female
Navi named tukatre their first adopted child is
Sigourney Weaver's character the female not being
named Kiri we don't know a ton of backstory about
her character yet or which family she came from
that they adopted her from in the circumstances
of her parents death I think it's implied that
it was just one of the conflicts with the other
human forces on the planet we know a little bit
about their other adopted child named Miles they
call him spider just because of what he he
does during the movie The Way They explain
his character is that he was the son of a couple
scientists that came as part of the settling crew
to try and mind the unobtainium and in a conflict
his parents were killed so Jake adopted him with
natiri and one of the other big changes from
the events of the first film is that the navi
have started working with some of the humans not
all the humans because one of the major villains
in the film is still quartz's character courage
is coming back but you probably recognize he's
also wearing the same Avatar body as Jake so the
whole idea is that korich is going to be one of
the main overarching villains heading into
the next couple of films so it sounds like
he will survive past the events of this film but
because his physical body was destroyed during the
last film when he was fighting with Jake who was
also in his Avatar body it seems like what court
has done is basically upload his Consciousness
into a copy of Jake's Avatar body like they had
multiple copies of Jake's avatars the way you
can tell which version of Jake you're looking
at is based on their hair and their tattoos so
the real Jake has the long hair no tattoos the
courage version of Jake has the short military
hear and Vibe about him like military clothing
and he has the same tattoo on his arm the courage
had so I think part of the idea is that they'll
play with that during the events of the film like
they'll make you think you're watching One version
of Jake when you're really watching the courage
version of Jake and he winds up doing a bunch of
evil stuff they have some voice over dialogue from
some of the other new characters inside this water
tribe that they travel to to Vin Diesel and Kate
Winslet were cast and they're part of this water
tribe but the way James Cameron described all
the Avatar sequels is that each film was sort
of meant to be its own Standalone thing even
though it's sort of continuing this overarching
story of Jake and natiri's family and throughout
his trailer it seems like we get a couple of time
jumps like there's a bit of a montage because
you see young versions of their family you see
older versions of the children I think they just
included that because it has been 13 years since
that first movie came out like okay it's been
a while we understand a lot has happened and
then so we're gonna tell you like a real quick
explainer as to how this family came to be it
also seems like Sigourney Weaver's character Kiri
will have a bigger arc in the movie too so they'll
need to explain some of her backstory most of the
footage here is just his family exploring during
this aquatic region as part of this water tribe
here one of the funny things you could say about
this trailer though is just trying to give you
Vibes for the movie because there's not a lot of
dialogue the first Avatar movie was fairly plotty
especially in the beginning they had to give you a
pretty quick tutorial about what the humans were
doing in the future why they needed this planet
what the unobtainium was for in its connection to
the navi and the planet itself the implies worth
billions of dollars the humans use it in all
their technology all their weapons everything
but I think part of the idea of the first movie
is that the mineral itself was critical to this
super organism on the planet this world brain
Eywa so the more the humans mine it the more
they hurt this world organism just because this
is like the second of five planned movies I'm not
expecting them to completely explain everything
that's going on with that Eywa creature it's sort
of like the Star Wars movies still not completely
explaining Yoda's character or the force there's
still a couple big Mysteries inside the Star Wars
Universe about how everything works exactly like
you know a little bit but not everything what
seems like happens though is they get into this
big battle with the humans and that might just
have something to do with quartz's character
because it seems like some of the other humans
they're also working with so like not all the
people are supposed to be bad this is a big reason
for taking them to this aquatic Coastal tribe was
just to make the family feel like fish out of
water like in the first movie Jake was this
big fish out of water because he was trying out
the Avatar bodies for the first time now he's
been living in one for the past 13 years he has a
bunch of biological Navi children so he's fairly
acclimated to the life in Pandora's jungles and
the way they switch that up is by taking them to
a completely new type of environment but the whole
idea is I think that through the course of all the
sequels we'll just explore all the different parts
of the planet so like in the next movie it won't
be another aquatic location it'll be some other
location they also reveal in the trail that not
all the navi are blue skin like there's a green
skin looking one it's the same vibe in real life
like around the world you have many different
people many different races with different skin
tones so you think of the navi the same way you
think of the human race there are many different
racial groups within the Navi and talking about
Vin Diesel memes like Vin Diesel is a character
in the movie one of the taglines of the movie is
this family is our Fortress so post all the Fast
and Furious family memes I don't know how many of
the sequels Jake and natiri are both going to be
and maybe they eventually wind up getting killed
off in one of the later sequels but the basic
idea for the sequels is that it's kind of them
doing the Skywalker Saga but with Jake and the
Terry's family you slowly see them age up through
the course of the sequels I don't know if that
means they're going to wind up killing off Jake
or natiri's character in one of the sequels like
Avatar 3 or Avatar 4 or Avatar 5 or something like
that but I think assuming they do make all those
sequels the the kids will be the main characters
by the time you get to Avatar 4 and Avatar 5. they
had like a crazy writer's room a couple years ago
you probably heard about where a bunch of writers
basically plotted out every single one of the
sequels you could post all your theories about
where you think the franchise is going to go after
this like we have the water-based movie in this
one what is the next movie going to be about which
area of the planet they're going to go to it just
feels like because this Eywa World brain creature
is such a huge force in Pandora throughout
the sequels they'll get closer and closer to
finding out what's going on with it like they
tease it being a God in the first movie eventually
they'll probably meet God because the trailer is
so cryptic I'm sure there's going to be a billion
questions that everybody has going into this movie
but I think that James Cameron wants it that way
like he wants you to be very confused and not sure
what's going on when you sit down in the theater
I'll do more bonus videos when they release the
next trailer if you have any big questions just
write them in the comments below and I'll try to
add them to my future bonus videos Everyone click
here for my Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
trailer with a whole bunch of Kang the Conquer
and click here for my new house the dragon season2
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!